hello there today we're going to look at
efficient and modular
implicit differentiation by researchers
of google
research this paper on a high level
extends what you know
from frameworks like tensorflow or pi
torch or jacks in terms of
automatic differentiation it extends it
to
multi-level optimization procedures
so this paper makes it possible that you
differentiate
through an inner optimization loop
without having to unroll
that inner optimization loop and without
having to implement
the optimization procedure in a
differentiable
way this has been done before
for single instances of problems
always with sort of specific uh
derivations for that particular problem
but this paper provides a unified
framework of doing this
and so a it's a bit of a technical paper
and we won't go
in this too technical mode because i'm
also
not the most or the biggest expert
on the methods used here i just wanted
to
raise a bit of awareness that this
exists because the ability to back
propagate through sort of inner
optimization procedures and
even like other things in a unified way
without having to unroll
i think it unlocks a bunch of research
that has been
quite cumbersome so far and could be
interesting to
a lot of people they do provide code and
everything
and they prove or they show that many
special instances that have been derived
in the past and also a bunch of
new ones are just instances of their
framework and can be
solved sometimes much more easily with
their framework
they even provide some approximation
guarantees and so on
i think interesting to us is just going
to be
a little bit of the insight of why and
how this works
and the fact that it exists so
let's jump in the they say that
automatic differentiation has
revolutionized machine learning it
allows expressing complex computations
by composing elementary ones in creative
ways
and removes the burden of computing
their derivatives by hand
this is absolutely true if you look at
old papers in
in deep learning half the paper would be
spent on
you know deriving the gradients of the
architecture that was just proposed so
you could actually implement it
and now we have autodiv which means that
the frameworks
they simply do this by themselves you
just compose a bunch of functions
and you call gradient on them this is
a big part of what has spurred the deep
learning
revolution in the past few years at
least from a implementation point of
view
right i don't think a lot of
architectures would have happened if
people always had to
derive the gradients by hand and it's
kind of obvious to do this
if you know the back prop algorithm but
still it is
a big helper now as i said this paper
makes this paper exposes or sorry this
paper
extends the concept the spirit of
autodiff
to a much larger class of applications
they say
more recently differentiation of
optimization problem solutions
has attracted widespread attention with
applications such as
optimization as a layer and in bi-level
problems such as hyper parameter
optimization and
meta learning so the key here is
differentiation of
optimization problem solutions so i
have an inner optimization problem and
i obtain a solution and i want to
back propagate through not only through
the solution itself but actually through
the path that led me to finding that
solution
and meta learning is a good example
hyper parameter optimization of course
as well so in meta learning
what you do and this is a this is a
simple thing there
there are many various tasks in meta
learning
but i've done a video on one of those
which is called
i mammal it's an extension of of
mammal and i think the ml stands for
meta-learning
the i here for implicit which is of
course going to be related
to the implicit differentiation we do
right here
or implicit the implicit here stands for
the fact that we can
implicitly derive the gradient we don't
have to go
through the whole unrolling so in imam
there is a setting
where you have multiple tasks you have
a data set and there is task one task
two
and task three so maybe this is
classifying food by taste this is
classifying food by
calories this is classifying food by
some other nutrient or a color or
something like this
now and this all should happen with the
same architecture of neural network
simply you know solving different tasks
so obviously the different tasks are
going to have different
optima different local optima and from
deep learning of course we know that
these are never in the same place there
are many local optima but let's just
pretend for a moment we knew that
these were the three optima the task of
meta learning
is can we find an initialization
that is really good such that
if we fine-tune on any of these tasks if
we if we get data from any of these
tasks
we can learn it really quickly so if you
know
you know if you see here if we choose
this as an initialization
it's going to take us a while to get to
any of these solutions
however if we choose this as our
initialization
we're here pretty quickly and in fact if
a new tasks comes that is
similar to the other ones let's say one
here right that's kind of similar it's
on the same
uh hyper plane what not you can see that
we're also there
fairly quickly so the question is how do
we find the blue
point uh obviously we don't know where
the green points are and
they're non-deterministic anyway and the
answer is
we start with any one like this one we
start with a guess
and we move point you know step by step
into
a better direction just as we do with
gradient descent
however how do we know what a good
direction is
in order to know what a good direction
is we need to know how good
is this initialization so consider this
one how good is this initialization
well in order to do that we actually
need to do
the optimization procedure so we do that
and we see well that leads us in that
direction we optimize for
a different task that leads us in that
direction and now we get an idea that
hey maybe
if all the tasks go into the same
direction
maybe you know it would be good if we
also went into that direction
specifically what we want is we want the
gradient
the gradient with respect to our
initialization
of the solution of a particular task
given that initialization right
now this solution itself
of course is an optimization procedure
so you have an inner optimization
procedure that you want to back
propagate
through what you usually have to do is
you have to unroll that optimization
procedure
so if you think of gradient descent so
here is your weights
and what you do is you subtract learning
rate
times the gradient so here is it at step
t
right um learning rate
with respect to the weights
of f of x and w
t okay that's your standard gradient
descent
so what does that give you all of that
gives you
w t plus one
and now you do another step of gradient
descent okay so
minus again gradient with respect to
this
this this maybe it's a different data
point maybe it's the same
plus one okay so it's
it already gets complicated because now
this
quantity here which is all the quantity
of above appears
twice okay and if you do another step
of course that quantity it is going to
to replicate and
and be anywhere an autodesk framework
can keep
track of that so if you do this
and you actually write down from your
first thing you write down
you can unroll all of this into one big
expression
that gives you the end of the
optimization procedure the end of
gradient descent given
the beginning you can do that and the
tensorflow or pi torch they can keep
track of this
it's just it's going to be a big
expression it's going to be
really really slow and further
what it needs what what you need to do
is you need to actually
implement the gradient descent procedure
as a differentiable procedure which is
usually not done
usually in especially in tensorflow and
pytorch the
gradient descent the optimization
procedures they're sort of
outside of the autodesk framework in jax
it's a bit different
but in in tensorflow and pytorch the
optimization procedures for good reason
they themselves aren't differentiable so
you'd have to re-implement them in a
differentiable way
all of that is fairly cumbersome
and uh people have asked themselves can
we do better
especially in this technique called eye
mammal
people have found that instead of
unrolling what we can do is if we
regularize this objective
in sort of a good way so we add some
sort of a
a regularizer here
then we can calculate the gradient this
outer gradient without having to go
through the whole unrolling step
a similar situation you can imagine with
hyper parameter optimization if you
actually want to do
gradient descent on your hyperparameter
so
you have some sort of a validation set
right
you want to minimize your
loss your validate loss on your
validation set
right of your um
of your of your with respect to your
hyper parameter lambda
okay and the solution you find
is you minimize with respect to the
weights
of your loss function on the training
set
i this is all green and looks horrible
but
okay i think that's it okay so
you want to for oh we need a lambda
we need a lambda right here okay
so for a given for a given lambda for a
given
hyper parameter
we want to find the best the best
weights okay
but then we want to find the best lambda
such that
the weights give us the best validation
loss right
such that the weights that came from the
training data that give us the best
validation loss
we do this right now with grid search
but we could definitely imagine
doing this with gradient descent if we
could get a gradient
for that hyper parameter but that
requires us to back propagate
through this inner optimization
procedure through the actual learning of
the neural network
now given that neural networks usually
train in thousands or millions of steps
uh unrolling that is not going to be an
option
like tensorflow is good but it's not
that good
okay so it can technically keep track of
it but it's just not going to be
possible
so for all of these problems or for many
of these problems people have devised
individual solutions like given very
very strict requirements given the exact
problem formulations
we do have solutions where we don't have
to unroll
however these are case by case and much
like the old papers on neural networks
where every time you
have to derive your gradient here every
every one of these papers has to sort of
derive
how they apply their conditions how they
do
how they apply the karush kuhn tucker
conditions in order to get
the implicit gradient and so on
and this here this paper is what what
autodiff is
for these old papers
so they go on yeah they say involves
case-by-case tedious mathematical
derivations in this paper we propose a
unified efficient and modular approach
for implicit differentiation of
optimization
problems in our approach the user
defines in
python in the case of our implementation
a function f
capturing the optimality conditions of
the problem to be differentiated
once this is done we leverage auto
default f and implicit differentiation
to automatically differentiate the
optimization
problem okay so what you do is
you don't you don't specify the gradient
of the optimization procedure
you specify a function that captures the
optimality conditions of the problem to
be differentiated
and if that function here is
differentiable
then this framework can do its its magic
to give you the gradient through the
optimization procedure
so we we shift away from the
optimization procedure itself
having to be differentiable to only the
specification of the optimality
conditions having to be
differentiable which is a huge gain
right
um yeah so they they say it can
it can be this can be actually done in
many ways uh
you can choose your solver and so on but
we'll go
through the through the very very basics
right here
okay this is ultimately
what is going to end up and this is
a problem of i think hyper parameter
optimization
as we saw so this is ridge regression
and
ridge regression is a you have a data
set
okay you have labels so x
is a is a matrix where each kind of row
i think is a or column i think row
as a data point and y is a vector of
labels numeric
labels uh and what you want to do is you
want to find
weights w such that
w times x
equals to y okay that is
linear regression of course now in ridge
regression
you have a regularization on y
sorry on w so it's easier you often to
specify the loss
so what you want is that this is small
but also that w
has some small norm and um
so you want this being small and you
want the norm of w also to be small
and this is a common regularization
technique
uh to want the norm of w to be small it
sort of means that your line kind of
stays
rather flat so if you have a bunch of
outliers
uh they won't affect your your
approximation too much
it's very it's a very common technique
the important part is there is a hyper
parameter right here
and this hyperparameter is
a matter of choice this is the
regularization constant
now with this framework we can run
gradient descent on that hyper parameter
and the way we have to we do it is the
following so
we start actually with down here so this
called ridge solver this is
the inner optimization this is the
solver
of the ridge regression now ridge
regression has a closed form
solution we can just solve we can put
this as a linear
problem so here you get x times x
and here we get x times y and then you
get yourself
a a diagonal matrix that you can
multiply
with the um with the regularization
constant
and then you can simply put up this
linear system so that's
the linear system corresponds to x
times x plus theta
well in this case in our case it was
lambda this
should equal to x times
y so if you solve this
um then you'll get if you solve this
you get the uh what am i saying
sorry the linear system is going to be
this times w
if you solve this for w you'll get the
direct solution to ridge
regression there's no gradient descent
here but
it would be totally cool if this
contained gradient descent
okay the next thing you'd have to do is
you have to specify the optimality
conditions
now in this case we're sort of going to
repeat the loss function
of range regression so as you can see
here
the optimality conditions of course are
dependent on
x here and x is going to be x is going
to be the
w actually what we call w
and theta is your hyperparameter so you
can see this is just the loss
here you multiply w by x
and subtract y that's what's called the
residual
and this here is the the square norm of
that
so in our loss function up here we'd
have sort of square l2 norms everywhere
and you can see here
this is the regularization and the half
here
is for easier differentiation we don't
have it
uh but doesn't matter okay so this
here is simply the loss function of
ridge regression you can imagine more
complicated things
um now if i give you the loss function
how do you what you need to give me is a
function that is
zero when optimality is met
and now that's pretty easy if i have a
loss function the gradient of that loss
function
is exactly such a function okay the
gradient of the loss function is
zero whenever the uh
inner problem is optimal so whenever the
ridge regression is solved
to optimality the gradient of
this loss function is zero
now we have all the ingredients so what
we can do now
is we can use their custom decorator
right here
to say that here is the optimality
condition f
is the optimality condition on this
inner optimization problem
and if you do this then you can just
back propagate through that so here you
can see that you can take the jacobian
of the ridge solver at
here this is lambda equals 10 for
example
so you can simply take derivatives
through the inner optimization procedure
because you have
supplied this without having to
back propagate through the inner
procedure itself
i hope this was a little bit clear
so again you need to specify of course
the inner procedure which is this thing
here
in our mid to learning case this would
be the gradient descent the inner
gradient descent
you need to specify the optimality
conditions which in the easy case is
simply
a loss function and then the optimality
condition
is the derivative or the gradient of the
loss function
it's optimal whenever that is zero
and you supply the optimality condition
in the custom annotation to the function
and then you can simply treat that inner
function
as if it were any other thing that you
could
back propagate through so cool so cool
okay they go into the they go into the
whole
math behind this and i don't want to go
too much
into the math but all of this
essentially comes from
the the implicit function theorem
so if you have this optimality condition
you
may have noticed it needs to be zero at
optimum
and this is what's called a root and
the root is specified like this so
you have this inner function that
depends on theta and you have the
optimality condition that depends on the
solution to the inner function and it
depends on the
or can depend on the parameter itself if
you have a construct like this
under some regularity conditions on f
you can
the implicit function theorem tells you
that in essence you can express the
gradient
of these things with respect to each
other
so from this you can get the derivative
of this inner thing you can get that
locally okay without having to
back propagate through the procedure of
how you found it
it's right it's so it's an implicit
gradient because
it's it's defined as a as implicitly
as a function of the other argument
right here
if you look at this thing and you take
the total derivative of this
right here you can use the chain rule
to arrive at the expression down here
so if you derive the first argument
right here you get the chain rule in
in in theta right
so you differentiate with respect to the
first argument and then you
also have to differentiate that first
argument right here
and then you differentiate with with
respect to the second argument and that
is
already theta of course so now you can
see we've ended up
with only partial derivatives right here
of simple arguments
so we need three things ultimately you
see this is the thing we want
the gradient of the solution of the
inner optimization procedure
now if we reorder a bit you can see the
other things that we need for that is
the number zero
that's easy we need two derivatives of
f both are just simple partial
derivatives with respect to the
arguments of f
and if f therefore is differentiable
then we can get those things right and
that's the exact shift i talked about
before so instead of the optimization
procedure having to be differentiable
only the optimality condition now needs
to be differentiable and that's a much
easier thing and again we can use
autodiff we can use these frameworks
for that so as long as we can specify f
in terms of somehow functions of the
framework
we're good the only so obviously the
this function here is fully
differentiable because it's the loss
of logistic regression the only tricky
thing right here
is that f big f capital f is actually
the gradient of that function
so what we need is uh the
framework to be able to differentiate
the gradient
again so to to obviously the
the gradient of or the derivative of
capital f
would be the derivative of the
derivative of lowercase
f but usually frameworks can do this
right and this loss function is
certainly differentiable
twice all right and then
it's just a linear system as you can see
down here so this
this is what they call a this is b
this is j so what you have to do is you
solve the
linear system ax plus sorry equals b
and then whatever comes out here that's
your gradient
and you can use any classic sort of
linear solver for that
so to repeat you obtain a and b
by using autodiff on the optimality
conditions
and then you simply have to solve a
linear system to get the gradient
of your solution of the inner
optimization problem
without ever having to unroll that inner
optimization procedure without having to
back propagate
through the steps of how you've how you
arrived
at that inner optimum and that's the
cool trick
right here so they can't only do this
with a root they can own
they can also do this with optimalities
that are
specified as fixed points so whenever
the optimal solution to the inner
problem has the property
of being a fixed point of some function
t can also
use this method so they i think they
provide two different decorators one is
custom root and
one is a custom fixed point and from
there you go
so they discuss what they need they
discuss the technicalities
they actually don't ever need to they
don't ever need to
calculate these things fully because
they could become pretty big
they actually only need to calculate
jacobian vector products
and vector jacobian products and they go
into the technicalities here
of how they obtain those and the cool
thing is
that this fully integrates with the
autodesk framework
so here they talk about pre-processing
and post-processing
mappings so you know what if we don't
need
the solution of the inner problem itself
what if we need
a function of that and so on this can
all be taken care of by the autodesk
framework
themselves uh sorry itself so they see
our
implementation is based on jacks
and they say it's it enters the picture
in at least two ways
we can lean heavily on jax within our
implementation
and we integrate the differentiation
routines
introduced by our framework into jax's
existing autodiv
system in doing the latter we override
jax's default autodiv
behavior eg of differentiating
transparently through an iterative
solvers unrolled iterations
so if you stick this in you can just
differentiate
through these things as if they were any
other differentiable function in jax
very very cool so the last thing
um so here are here are all the
the different things that reduce to
their method if you actually
if you go and look they give a lot of
different
examples of what other techniques reduce
to their methods especially specifically
you know we've seen the simple
optimization procedures but you can also
do sort of proximal methods in the inner
optimization problem
you can do things like projected
gradient fixed point which is maybe
important for something like adversarial
examples
where you have to minimize a function
but at the same time you have to stay
within some convex
set so you always back project onto
that set uh so now we can back propagate
through the procedure of finding an
adversarial example
very cool and they even give
bounds because you cannot ever exactly
calculate these things so they give
bounds on how far you're off
and lastly they do experiments and these
are just
more examples so their first experiment
pretty straightforward hyperparameter
optimization of multi-class
svms so in a support vector machine you
generally
have a hyperparameter and that
hyperparameter
um here is sort of the
the strength of the regularization
or or like how how much you trade off
margin
um versus slack i believe
i i've done svms in a long time
especially multi-class
yet you need to stay within sorry sorry
you need to
you need to maximize the margin while
staying within
the probability simplex because it's
multi-class
so that's kind of a constrained inner
problem but you would
like to find the best hyper parameter
for the trade-off parameter for the svm
uh with respect to an outer validation
set okay so you know that's
that's a a problem with two levels and
they can
do it right here they can do dictionary
learning
so in usually in dictionary learning
it's
it's not you need to somehow obtain the
dictionary
and then you optimize using the
dictionary so in dictionary learning you
have a some sort of a data point maybe
an image
and you map that into entries in a
dictionary
and then you use those entries to do
something with it and then you have some
kind of a loss right here
however you can't optimize these
functions that map and the dictionary
itself at the same time it becomes
unstable so what people do is they do
alternating or they
have also they back propagate through
some inner thing
you know in this thing you can actually
back propagate through the inner thing
through the inner problem and find those
dictionary elements as a function of
which
dictionary elements would actually most
optimally solve the outer problems
lastly this is data set distillation
they want to find the optimal data set
of
size 10 right this is the data set
that so if give me one image per class
and if i train a neural network or
whatever on that class on that
data set of ten images i want the best
possible validation loss okay and
that is an optimization problem so what
you need to do is you need to start with
10 random images
you train your classifier you measure it
on the
on the validation set or whatever the
test
set um and then you back propagate
through the whole thing to update
your data set itself and in the end you
end up with the optimal data
set you can see that this is also a two
level optimization problem
uh with maybe some constraints right
here
i think this is a very cool idea
honestly it's probably i mean it
existed before but uh you can now do
this
and in last they have these molecular
dynamics where they
uh want to to see if we changed kind of
the size of these molecules
how do all of these things change so on
again this reduces to
quite complex this is the inner problem
right here but
i think the point of all of this is that
if you have a problem
where it has sort of an outer and inner
optimization structure
and you want to use back propagation for
the outer problem through the inner
problem
give this method a try it's pretty cool
if you're interested in
the more technical aspect give it a read
and that was it
from me i wish you a pleasant rest of
the day
bye bye